Bernie hey how you doing man very
badly I'd missed my daughter's birthday
I'm going to take Eve to my mom's my
wife left me and then I got fired I want
you out today that's when I happened to
on this old antique jewelry box and then
I rubbed
it God who are you I am a genie yeah go
your wish is my command okay I wish I
had my very own
camel if you're an actual Genie explain
the whole three wishes thing fairy tale
stuff real genies unlimited
wishes I wish I had large pizza
pepperoni extra
cheese this is just a triangle of Red
Bread go and try
it wait an ever loving minute this is
heaven it's the most Wonder this place
is Big you've OB s been inside that b
slightly longer than you think how long
are we talking about look what I found
2,000 years what do you call it oh
sanitizer
zesty I need to get my wife and kids to
love me again and for us to be happy s
kind is sprucing up to
place uh go make it the mo
Lisa
I mean she could have smiled
right years from now I want you to
remember he the very best friend that
they ever
had you're going to love
[Music]
this so tell me about this whole
Christmas thing of yours it was meant to
celebrate the birth of Jesus Christ
Jesus are you talking about Mary's kid
you actually met him what did he do to
get so famous we turn out to be Son of
God oh no I thought he was
[Music]
kidding